- Welcome back, everybody!
Back when they were teenagers,
these guys were band members
in real life and on TV,
they went their separate ways
after the show ended in 2014,
but reunited just a few years ago
and have become a huge success once again
with over 2 billion global
streams of their music.
(audience cheers)
You can check out (audience cheering)
I said billion, that's a lot!
You can check out the new deluxe version
of their Another Life album, it's out now,
please welcome the guys
from Big Time Rush!
(audience cheers loudly)
Carlos Penavega,
Kendall Schmidt, James
Maslow, Logan Henderson.
(upbeat instrumental music)
(audience cheering)
What's up y'all?
- Look at that.
- I am very into this.
- Yes.
- [Kelly] Yes.
- I'm a horse guy, so.
- Yeah, I'm, I love green
too, it's my favorite color.
- You can have it.
- Yep, thank you.
- Oh, wow.
- It's actually very soft, too.
But why reunite now?
Congratulations, by the way,
on the second round of success.
- Thank you.
(audience cheers)
- Why did you think now was
like, the time to do it?
- Well, it's been about
three years now actually.
It's something we had spoken about a bunch
and over the years, you know, the timing
with our personal schedules,
finding the right team
never quite added up, and then we finally
put everything in line,
it worked out for us,
and man, we are just so happy to be back.
- Worked out, you're selling
out Madison Square Garden,
the Forum, the (audience cheers)
Like, you're killing it, that's amaze--
Do you find that, what about the fan base?
'Cause it's gotta be a
little different, right,
from when you first started as well.
Like do you find that
they're new fans, old fans,
or just a really good mixture?
- Yeah, I mean, we got
lucky, 'cause our fans
were amazing back then,
they're all older now,
some of them even have kids now...
- [Kelly] Yeah, oh, so they're
bringing their kids, right?
- Right, but then, the
amazing world of streaming,
our show got picked up again,
so we have this
- And it comes, yeah!
- new generation of
kids, so now we go out,
and we're in the audience, and
they're six, they're eight,
they're 25, they're 30, and we're like.
- [Kendall] My grandma's also there.
- A grandma's there.
- Yeah.
- Grandma Boots.
- Grandma Boots!
- But Carlos's kids are
also watching it, so.
- Yeah, yeah, it's, got
the whole, it's fun.
- Oh my, oh that's kinda cool.
That your kids are, like, into it.
- Oh, my kids, I mean, I
think our first tour back
was when they really were like,
"My dad's cool."
(audience laughs)
- Oh, that's a win, man.
- [Carlos] And hold on, we
did one show, and Ocean,
- [Audience] Aww.
- Oh there they are, yeah.
Ocean, my oldest, it's
actually his birthday today.
- [Kelly] Aww.
- [James] Happy birthday!
- He runs up to me, and he goes,
"I'm so proud of you, Daddy."
- [Audience] Aww.
And I was just like, "Oh my
God, I love you, just stop."
- I would break down.
And it's so cool when
you're cool to your kids.
Like, it's like you could win
awards, you could do stuff,
but when your kid looks at
you like you're like, Thor,
- Oh, yeah.
- You're like, "Oh my
God," like, it's magical.
So what about, I have to
ask 'cause a lot of artists
have like pre-show
things, y'all do a quack?
What, now what do ya do?
- Yeah, we do.
It's like a Mighty Ducks kind of quack.
- I love the Mighty Ducks!
- Yeah, there's four grown
men making a quack sound,
it just kinda gets you outta your head.
- [Kelly] I wanna quack!
How do you--
- We incorporate everyone.
So we incorporate our crew
and anybody who's around we bring in.
So come on in.
- Okay, I'm coming in.
- Hands in, right before we go.
- Oh, hands in!
- Hands in.
- Words of wisdom.
- Yes!
- We ask for words of wisdom.
- I have dry hands, I'm so sorry.
Okay.
- It's all good.
- Are those the words of wisdom?
- Yep.
- You gotta give it some--
- Use more lotion.
- What would you tell us before a show?
Words of wisdom before.
- Don't suck.
- Okay.
- Don't suck!
- And... Quack! Quack!
Quack! Quack! Quack! Quack!
Quack! Quack! Quack! Quack! Yay!
(audience cheers)
- Okay! Alright, alright.
So y'all been doing that
since the beginning?
- Since the beginning.
Every single show, it's
good luck, we have to do it.
- Yeah, since I was nineteen.
- Miss it twice.
- We said those
words of wisdom before, don't suck.
- Don't suck.
- You lotion your hands
and don't suck.
- Well, here's my thing,
I kept it family friendly,
that's not what I say (laughs).
I usually am messing with my band,
I'll pick like one person, I'm like,
"Don't you (beep) this up."
And I'm totally messing with
everyone, but it's the, yeah,
it breaks the ice.
- Yes.
- You know, when you get out there.
So wait, what's the song
that you're performing later?
Let's talk about that one.
- Ooh! One of our favorites.
- Weekends.
- [Kelly] Okay,
is it Weekends?
- It's called Weekends, yeah.
- Well those are fun.
- [Logan] They are, they are.
- What a great title, yeah.
What's it about?
- Well, first off, it's a song that's
- Actually not as fun.
(Carlos laughs and talks indistinctly)
- It's very dark.
- It's kind of about getting ghosted.
But you know what I love
about the song though,
is that the way it came
about, the four of us,
you know, we live in
different parts of the world,
so when we get together, it's flying in
and we try and pick fun locations.
So we had to finish the
album, we went to Big Bear,
rented a cabin.
- Selfishly.
- Yeah, well if you gotta fly anywhere,
- [Kelly] Big Bear's awesome!
- you might as well fly somewhere fun.
- But anyways, this is
one of a couple of songs
that came out of that trip
and it really is so much better for us
when we get to be in the same
room to write music together
versus somebody writes a song,
and then you have to cut it
and kinda make it work.
And this was one of those,
I think it's special 'cause
we all did it together.
- You know how it is when
a song surprises you,
you finish it and then when
it gets really done-done,
and then you're like, "I
think I like this the most!"
- [Kelly] Yeah, it's like a dark horse.
- Yeah!
- You were like, "I was almost
gonna not put that on the album!"
- [Logan] Yeah, almost.
- Yeah!
- And this version is
our acoustic version,
which just came out on the deluxe album,
and I think I like it even
better than the original.
- I always like acoustic better.
- [Kendall] Yeah, it's a
completely different experience.
(audience cheers)
- 'Cause when you can break down the song,
and hear it like that,
that means it's a really excellent song
and it still captivates you.
- Yeah.
- Yeah. Agreed.